yeah hello to more people so many people
someone use the holo command das Auto
let's play das although das auto gifted
subs of previous stream and the stream
before that I think we've played we
played once which I vaguely remember the
game
oh yeah the G for me that was nice I'll
play on hopefully for I'll try and play
aggressively oh I know what opening I
want to play let's see if it actually
comes to comes to life yeah what does
this carnage yeah
anyone know what opening this is there
should be at least a few people this is
my first time ever at least on stream
playing this some is Jerome gambit I
think it went slightly viral recently
there is a chest broad video they were
there is a lot of memes all over the
place a lot of people in the chat
requesting the the Jerome gambit
ooh the counter gambit is this I feel
like this is maybe a novelty this is a
free night opponent gambling back emblem
was I supposed to play queen h5 ooh I'm
very new to this opening so please
forgive me if I mess up but that's how
you learn okay so I'm I'm losing a pawn
I'm gonna lose the e4 pawn but I should
save my queen and quina for blunders our
queen we enough 5 doesn't seem right
it's really just a question where the
Queen should go
Queen g3 there's a Knight takes e4 maybe
Queen a5 seems weird
there's also Queen g5 which is kind of
interesting
hey Queen g5
it's kind of a question of which king is
is less safe oh man people in the chat
saying hey I miss played it I I guess I
I wasn't aware to play Queen h5 I just
assumed I I could win back the piece but
okay well it'll take I'll analyze
afterwards this is a whole kind of
learning experience
maybe f3 always play off 3 and I
probably want to put the king on f2 I
think a lot of players would Castle but
the king is probably just more useful in
the center I could start with knight
Knight c3 let's start with king f2 not
entirely sure how I want to develop the
Queen side and I played King f2 assuming
that at some point rocky 8 will come so
I know my king wants to be here let's
play Knight c3 I think the idea is
Bishop g5 and this is a very very quiet
Jerome gambit like we just like I tried
to gambit I miss play that opponent gave
me back a piece and now it's uh it's a
queenless middle game I kind of gamma to
the pawn there but then I would have had
some open file action ok so let's take
and balance things a little bit tog II
welcome back how's it going tog II see
the tog emotes along with the tog II
username yeah ideally I would not want
to play rook c1 cuz it's kind of passive
G for Bishop take C to rook c1 let's
play Knight d5 just hitting the pawn if
c6 then probably 93 attack and defend
did it freeze uh oh no I'm so sorry if
it rose
um but it's back yeah sometimes the
frozen rosin will make unwanted
appearances or maybe it's witches fault
well it's probably my fault I'll take
responsibility
ooh wait what oh this is three o da ha
I was so encapsulated with the chat and
the fact that I'm playing the Jerome I
forgot it's like I basically gambit in
my time that's not good let's play a
three yeah that's nice
I'll pre move there okay supreme of time
hmm I can move oh that's not good this
is really bad now this is really bad I'm
down a piece thankfully this is casual
blitz I can visit too many things okay a
for coming maybe a for is coming
ooh opponent one connect for but I have
some pawns
okay let's see how my opponents angry
technique will be that's pretty good my
phone to see the clock did see Rosen
stream and got here on min - oh and I'll
expect him king g6 I mean I'm in big
trouble if you're just joining in very
big trouble I need I need to pull out
some some tricks of some sorts but I
don't like my chances yes
Rosen trap that's kind of right I mean
the a3 wasn't pre moved also I was
flagging while the game opponent still
needed I think
yeah a3 definitely was not pre moved
that's why you never gave up kids to
roam gambit stalemate trap I gamma did
way too many things a king I think
that's you to burry though that's
probably youtuber thee just for you to
people to I should really learn some
some opening theory this is cutting edge
even though some people maybe many
people might now know it so apparently
Queen h5 wait the stock fish just says
whites losing d4 is the best move what
am I supposed to play Queen h5 o Queen
h5 check ah interesting
Wow King e6 f4 okay I'll play this next
next time if I ever decide to fight this
opening again so it does look
interesting
if King e6 is a mainline then there's
probably some some sort of compensation
I don't know
anyway YouTube people hope you enjoyed
that you can say hi to the twitch people
hopefully the lag wasn't too bad but
yeah say hi to the the twitch chat ooh
what did I just do - I did something
what do they do there we go wait where's
the twitch chat there's a twitch chat ok
um say hi and oh thanks so much a KD 707
thank you to beam counter-strike and say
hi to tog II to tog II somewhere
somewhere lurking okay